[Music]
isn't this supposed to unlock with my
face I thought this was oh it's no it's
not that this is not the iPhone X or
iPhone 10 phone with a face ID and the
no bezels the phone you've been hearing
about for weeks that supposedly contains
all secrets to the future of the
universe this is not that phone this is
the iPhone eight and this is the iPhone
eight plus these are the phones that
everyone kind of figured would come out
this year they're the same as the iPhone
seven just better in lots of little ways
if you're already an iPhone user there's
nothing terribly surprising here
home-button
still here headphone jack still gone so
it looks familiar
apples even gone back to the glass and
metal design of some of its older
iPhones these phones are so much nicer
looking and more impressive to hold than
the last ones and I also really dig this
new gold color since they are all glass
on the front and back you'd be right to
be worried about breaking this fancy in
your plaything I haven't broken either
of these new phones but it's only been a
week and I do already have a couple of
little scratches I wouldn't say you need
to baby them but you might want a case
just for your own peace of mind
both models have slightly upgraded
screens with wider color gamut sand that
true tone technology that automatically
adapts your phone's white balance to
whatever roomier they also have better
stereo speakers upgraded Bluetooth and a
bunch of other small changes like the
ones Apple makes every year all are good
things for sure but I can't say any of
them have made a difference in how I use
or feel about my iPhone this might sound
crazy but the most important feature on
the iPhone eight might be a technology
that's been on other phones for a decade
lots of Android users know how great
wireless charging is you can just drop
your phone on a pad and have that
battery icon start filling up with
Korean it works just as it should on the
iPhone eight you might have to jostle it
around a little to get it to charge but
mostly you just set it down and get on
with your life since iPhone users are
new to this very old tech of wireless
charging a couple of things you should
know first of all it's not fast the
iPhone 8 and 8 plus charge dramatically
more slowly on this Mophie pad I have
than when I plug them straight into the
wall totally fine for charging overnight
but I still keep a plug around for those
last-minute tops seriously though
wireless charging is awesome Apple's way
late to the party but I'm glad it's here
as usual though most of the upgrades on
the iPhone 8
our internal one there's the new
processor called the a11 Bionic which
has a custom GPU and a separate chip for
neural networks and none of that needs
to mean anything to you but this thing
runs more like a laptop than a
smartphone it's absurdly fast and you
notice it playing games or even just
switching between apps there's also a
new camera in both phones 112 megapixel
shooter in the iPhone 8 and 2 in the
iPhone 8 plus the specs are about the
same as last year but they have a new
design and a new sensor this won't shock
you but the new iPhones take amazing
photos video apples even changed its
approach a little tuning the camera
software to make all the colors a bit
more bright and vivid
so everything pops more than it used to
really all of the best stuff about the
iPhone 8 and a plus comes from that
combination of the incredibly fast
processor in the killer cameras put them
together and suddenly the iPhone 8
shoots this beautiful 4k video at 60
frames per second or slow-motion 1080p
video at 240 frames per second on the 8
plus you get not just the portrait mode
which uses both cameras to do some soft
background shots and it's gotten really
good by the way but also a new feature
that lets you reimagine your photo with
super dramatic stage lights or a perfect
portrait lighting even beyond just
taking pictures and shooting video the
camera and processor combined to make
totally new stuff possible with iOS 11
and the AR kit software all sorts of
cool augmented reality apps are starting
to hit the App Store and all of them run
really well I'm still not a hundred
percent sure why I would want to look at
a giant beating heart in the middle of
the office or just sit here measuring
things all freaking day but I can and it
works
normally I get about the same life from
an 8 that I did from a 7 a day for the 8
a day and a third from the 8 plus you'll
want to charge both every night
obviously but as soon as you fire up AR
apps or even just shoot lots of high res
or high frame rate video you're gonna
want that charging pad nearby in a lot
of ways actually in most ways the
updates Apple made to the iPhone 8 and 8
plus feel straightforward they're what
you'd expect especially when you compare
them to the other iPhone that Apple
announced this fall at the same time the
iPhone 8 and 8 plus are truly excellent
phones if you can deal with the size you
should get the 8 plus you're gonna want
the extra battery and all the power in
those 2 cameras
I would bet this phone is going to do
more and better AR things than any
Android device and it's probably the
best and most powerful phone camera out
there
it's everything an iPhone should be even
if it doesn't feel brand-new oh and good
news it doesn't cost $1000